I'm still not up on the um
they still frightened no no no get the
almond milk I just got up on two percent
milk a couple no no no no no no get the
almond milk now y'all trying to
conspiracy no no no no no and it's the
question is it from the Almond of the
Walnut is they squeezing it out of the
peanut I don't have that answer and I
usually have every answer
[Music]
today we're going to be debating the
greatest snack of all time
this debate will have an opening
statement three rounds a final closing
statement unfortunately we have to do
family business I love my opponent I'm
just putting them up on game today
what's the greatest snack of all time
that's got to be the easiest question
I've ever been asked easy
that's the Rick Ross version the rap
snacks and when I say the Rick Ross
version I'm talking to Rose cheddar late
night it's nothing like Windows
double doors open up you feel me after
the club though Keith you don't already
ate branzinos you don't already ate
rigatoni
flowers which she's substituting the mac
and cheese right but you coming in after
the club a little twisted but you gotta
put something on your stomach before you
go to sleep
my brother DJ Khaled big question what
is the greatest snack
of all terms I mean for me it has to be
the cinnamon toast crunch
but the key is we're almond milk see
that's the key that's the problem a lot
of people just be putting milk like [ __ ]
in school I'm not gonna lie to you I
like it soggy I'm saying like like the
the cinnamon toast sauce yeah I let it
sit
hold on let me tell you something when
you mentioned late night late night
that's what we're talking I call this
late night snack but I also call it a
great night imagine just getting done
recording one of your biggest records
and you just know it's the [ __ ] and then
you coming from the studio and you're
walking in the crib and you crack that
bowl and put a little almond milk and
Cinnamon Toast Crunch on it then you go
boom
and have a spliff knowing you just made
the biggest record in the world
round one I'm going with the Cinnamon
Toast Crunch sweet you know what
because people out there think life is
sweet see at least I get it tasted and
enjoy it while they getting tricked
knowing this [ __ ] is hard out here and
they trying to finish us
you know I rock with rap snacks you know
I got that you know I rock with it but
late night why would you pick something
Savior and not something like
how can I say sweet but refreshing
that's the word I was looking for
refresh you because you know when you
eat chips at night you know it's it's a
lot going on we always got to brush our
teeth but now you really you know you
really can't miss the thing it's just a
rinse
you know what I'm saying
I'm gonna keep it real rap snacks got a
real team they know they chipped so
everybody chip got a Vibe but like I
said number one the rose cheddar the
rose chatter man it's the champagne of
potato chip like I told you I stacked
line
layer
it's like a little sandwich late night
you know what I'm talking about all you
got to do the fathom this right now is
just imagine coming home from the club
you know what I mean but hold up what's
the outcome meaning as in after you
enjoy it you know you're going to bed
it's your stomach bubbling like are you
like no I'm saying when you're going to
knock no no no I know it's good but
sometimes are you going to bed and we
good no late night now no no no no no
I'm most definitely gonna have my date
for the night of my you know my young
lady she's gonna be laying in the bed or
waiting my presence so she usually have
to have a little patience while I enjoy
the rose jealous you know what I mean
and after I enjoy the chips then I go
ahead and devour the situation you know
round two
well growing up that's right growing up
as a shorty in Kansas City that's right
you had to be somebody if you desired
that Mercedes-Benz if you wanted to get
a garage one day cause you never had one
of those you don't know what to feel
like I know where you're going I know
where you go up in something I know
where you're going with it you
understand what I'm trying to say oh I'm
clear so guess what as a shorty I said
damn I want to be like Bo Jackson that's
right I want to be like
Daryl strawberry yeah that's coming from
nothing to something so guess what now
you pulling up to the gas station it's 4
47 a.m you just left the club guess what
your gas light on Boom your chicken the
carpool your homies in the backseat
[ __ ] everybody get out let's go in
the gas station somebody digging for
pocket change and they they part you
know
they pull that door open in that
7-Eleven and everybody listening
remember it's 4 47 A.M
you know it's a different type of vibe
now keep going you pull those double
doors open
you could smell those 99 cent hot dogs
on that Grill over there and then the
pizza's under it like you know and
you're trying to figure out
it's 4 47 a.m I'm trying to tell you and
it's 7-Eleven we came here again with
you you feel me but guess what as soon
as you swing your head to the left and
it's by some rack right there that rack
that ride that rack is always up front
I know about and it's
you know about that rack 4 47 a.m you
know what I'm saying that at 7-Eleven
you grabbing that [ __ ] now even if
you're not eating and you've got to grab
them because it's right there guess who
everybody see right there
that's right yeah that's inspiration
it's inspiration guess what we came from
nothing that's right now we on the
potato chips like boat checks God did
God did it if ain't nobody else heard us
guess who did God did
nah that's real talk
Studio shooting a video [ __ ] dealing
with all the lawyers money you know all
that this just you know all the hard
work we wires light right greatness did
it be 4 47 A.M
walk in the crib take your shirt off
feeling sexy taking a shirt off you in
your boxes and then you get the bowl the
bowl got to be one of the big bulbs
right nice bowls yeah but it gotta be
thick like the [ __ ] heavy before you
even put the [ __ ] in it it's glass yeah
it's it's so heavy when you put on a
table my wife's screaming like yo you're
making too much noise Damon get started
then the spoon
hitting the count of the Granite you
reflect on life you realize
all the mileage you put in
all that [ __ ] we go through every single
day that one bite of the Cinnamon Toast
Crunch it was all worth it nobody in the
kitchen with you and you just reflect on
life after that one by the cereal wow
bought a crib I got one bite of cereal
dropped the number one album I can write
one by the cereal let's have more kids
after that one bite of cereal honey
let's go shopping after that what all
this at 4 47 a.m that first scoop is
that Eyes Open the Eyes Closed am I
gonna lie to you imma be very honest
with you it's both
oh because it's like you look at it and
you make sure you got and then then you
close it and then you that's where the
reflection comes in so I want you to
know how important that one [ __ ] bite
was
yes yes
connecting with the omen yes
round three what I love about it is I
want to ask you the question how not
only is the inspiring motivating that
you have your own chips
that also represents
our life our story you know the culture
talk to me how it's the impact of rap
snacks right because it's about the
culture because it's black owned James
Lindsey that's right it's a brother I
met running in the back streets in the
clubs promoting artists and he actually
was managing Meek Mill when I was
introduced to meat that's over a decade
ago so he been really grinding and I
love to be a part of History that's
right I see this being bigger than wives
big bigger than Ruffles that's right you
understand what I'm trying to say so I
reached out to the homie hey homie I see
what you got going I didn't tried all
the chips I love them Rose need his face
on some I'm bigger than Bo Jackson I
like that and guess what we made it
happen came up with the rose shutters we
on fire but more importantly look who
else on the bags no that's what I did a
dream was young entrepreneur yeah I love
that I love that so that's why I wanted
to join the movement just to push it for
the brothers and the other sisters
that's involved with it that's what I
love
that's what we love
what I want to know is what really
separated that Cinnamon Toast Crunch
moment from all those other honey Smacks
Captain Crunch
the Honey Nut Cheerios what was it
really about that Cinnamon Toast Crunch
170 calories because some of them are
550 and 650 and you like damn when I
found out it was 170 calories I'm like
all right we can get away with this and
we can still we can still buy but also
Rose you know it goes back to the wrap
snacks I be asking myself
cinnamon toast saying figure it out yet
why they ain't reach out you ain't got
cavity on the cover on the box
like you ain't figure it out yet
somebody got to get me their number or
imma hit them on Twitter or the deal
Rose nah you know what's crazy they sent
me one with my face and everything on it
just for me I was like nah what the
streets needed that's what I was trying
to explain I said the world need to feel
that and see that to let them know it's
possible to get your face on a Cinnamon
Toast Crunch and be on the box God did
God did this is the closing statement I
know it's a different way we do it but
we don't before you do it over let it
let it Vibe first level five go ahead
let it Bob let it Vibe
um can we get some spoons over here
please
this GQ they have everything
think about the original milk that you
used to eat and I think about this one
in the back of my mind I say is they
squeezing it out of the peanut there's
no way in the world I'm gonna go against
what's better you know what because each
moment for for each person different and
when he broke down how rap snacks was to
me I felt that that's seven eleven at 4
47 a.m you have a chance to get that
dried up hot dog or that pizza that's
been sitting there for 10 years or you
can get that front row potato chips with
your idol on it I'm going for the chips
and stack the chips we're gonna come
down to the Cinnamon Toast Crunch this
is when you come in the crib this is at
4 47 a.m after you work so hard you've
been through so much [ __ ] and you took
your shirt off and the AC is on like I
told you I stat in line layer
oh god dude
all glory to God if you know I won put
it in the comments right now say Rosie
everybody knows who won I do
but everybody has an opinion and I don't
care about tripping me now pause two
glasses of almond milk fresh yeah